aquí el punto para aprender ecuaciones
diferenciales es poder usarlas para
eventualmente modelar algo de la vida
real todo lo que hemos hecho hasta el
momento es crear un conjunto de
herramientas que nos permitan
resolverlas pero eso se debe a que las
ecuaciones diferenciales pueden escribir
diferentes sistemas a los que
eventualmente podremos modelar y sabemos
que en la vida real no todos son
funciones continuadas bonitas por eso en
los próximos vídeos vamos a hablar sobre
funciones que son un poco más
discontinuas de lo que estamos
acostumbrados a ver en nuestras clases
tradicionales de cálculo y la primera
que veremos es la función escalón
unitario se escribe como un subíndice c
y se define como
bueno se define como 0 cuando t es menor
que el subíndice que yo haya escrito
aquí en este caso sé cuándo t es menor
que ese y se define como uno cuando t es
mayor o igual que sé y si ustedes
quisieran graficar a esto lo pueden
hacer realmente no es nada difícil voy a
dibujar mi récord de nado mi eje x aquí
en un bonito color verde
voy a poner mi eje de aquí
cuando hablemos de las tan sonadas de la
plaza que es a lo que nos vamos a
referir aquí solo nos van a interesar
los valores de la función cuando t es
mayor a 0 de todas maneras nuestra
definición de la transformada de la
plaza es la integral que va de 0 a
infinito por lo que siempre vamos a
estar trabajando con la parte positiva
de esta función
de cualquier manera vamos a tener el
valor de 0 hasta que lleguemos a algún
valor a nuestro valor c en este caso
entonces vamos a tener un cero hasta que
llegamos a c y es que tenemos un salto
como si tuviera un escalón de ahí viene
el nombre volvemos a ponerlo aquí en
este punto y ese es nuestro valor 1 en
este caso de la función y a partir de
aquí todo el valor siguiente va a ser
igual a 11 pero bueno ustedes me pueden
decir oye me acabas de decir que vamos a
usar ecuaciones diferenciales para
modelar cosas y qué me sirve ver esto
bueno en el mundo real existen
situaciones en la que tenemos un valor y
de repente ese valor salta o brinca
aunque no hay nada que tenga un cambio
tan brusco como esto pero si tenemos
situaciones en donde podemos ver que hay
un valor que no pasa nada se mantiene
ese valor y de repente llega a un punto
en el que él
y esta función es una muy buena
aproximación analítica para modelar este
tipo de comportamiento siempre que
estamos viendo estas ecuaciones
diferenciales de manera analítica vamos
a tratar de encontrar un modelo puro de
algo aunque eventualmente veremos que
ningún modelo define o describe
perfectamente una situación del mundo
real pero nos ayuda a describirlo
suficientemente bien como para que
podamos analizarlo pero bueno vamos a
borrar esto de aquí para continuar con
nuestro análisis bueno la primera
pregunta al respecto es qué tal si algo
no se comporta exactamente como esto qué
tal si yo quisiera hacer
si yo quisiera hacer unas funciones
escalón un poquito más sofisticadas qué
tal si yo quisiera construir algo que se
viera como esto digamos que esto esta es
mi eje y éste es mi eje x y digamos que
quiero construir algo que luce más o
menos en otro color lo voy a poner este
es un 2
hasta que llegó hasta que llegó el valor
de pi
valor de pi 3.14 16 y cuando lee este
valor va a continuar siendo 0 cómo puedo
yo construir esta función usando lo que
sé de mi función escalón unitario muy
bien pensemos un poco al respecto y qué
pasaría si yo reescribir a esto de
manera que escribo
2 - la función escalona unitario que es
un es mi función escalón unitario que va
a comenzar desde el valor de pi y es una
función de t si yo definiera esto como
mi función ft bueno como está definida
esta función escalón sería igual a 1
cuando llegue al valor de pin pero
queremos que tenga el valor de 2 así que
aquí le vamos a multiplicar por un 2 y
ya con esto debe de funcionar mientras
tengamos un valor que sea menor
y mientras sea un valor menor a pie esto
va a tender a cero así que la función se
va a evaluar en dos pero en cuanto
lleguemos a que te sea igual y
recordemos que es nuestra c en este
ejemplo y en cuanto llegue a este valor
nuestra función escalón se va a volver 1
por lo que va a ser 2 menos 2 igual a 0
y nuestra función a partir de este punto
va a ser igual a 0 y bueno todo esto
está muy bien pero qué pasaría si
ustedes necesitaran regresar un paso que
el lugar en lugar de tener la función
como esto
vamos a estar quitando esto voy a borrar
esto de aquí quiero que vuelva a brincar
mi función quiero que vuelva a tomar el
valor de 2 después o cuando llegue a
otro valor más al reiba de pi digamos
doble de pi como construiremos esa
función y no queremos que salte a
cualquier lugar queremos que regrese al
valor de 2
bueno pues podemos agregar otra función
a escala ahora esta va a ser cero
durante todo el tiempo pero va a saltar
a dos en el momento en el que llegue a
dos pie así que en este caso con nuestra
nueva función escalón nuestra se va a
ser igual a dos pi y recordemos que la
función escalón solita saltaría 1 y lo
que queremos es que salte a 2 así que la
vamos a multiplicar por 2 y de esta
manera ustedes pueden crear sus propias
funciones arbitrarias en las que pueden
ir brincando de arriba a abajo como
ustedes lo prefieran simplemente usando
diferentes combinaciones lineales de
esta función escalón pero ahora vamos a
hacer algo todavía un poco más
sofisticado digamos que tengo una
función que luce así
más o menos así aquí está de nuevo mi
eje
mi eje de mi eje x y digamos que mi
función
efe dt este es x bueno no no de hecho
aquí debe ser una t porque mis funciones
están con respecto a t así que ésta va a
ser efe dt y aquí voy a dibujar algo
completamente arbitrarias digamos que es
pongo esta curva así
y qué tal si yo modelar a esto de la
siguiente manera esta es mi ft
y si yo modelar a este sistema de la
siguiente manera digamos que se va a
mantener en cero hasta cierto valor se
va a mantener en cero hasta que llegue
al valor que es nuestra sed
y aquí se empieza a elevar nuestra
función
cuando llegase y comienza a hacer algo
así
bueno de hecho lo que tenemos aquí es
una combinación en donde se tiene cero y
después se tiene un desplazamiento a ft
llegándose se desplaza hacia este lado
como podríamos modelar esta función
amarilla pues es la misma función que la
función verde de ft pero tiene un valor
de 0 y en el momento en el que llegue
hace es que se da esta función
esta función verde puede estar así o
puede haber continuado más o menos así
pero nosotros lo único que hicimos es
desplazar la de aquí para acá y dejar en
cero todo lo que estaba antes de ser
bueno como es que hacemos esto bueno
ustedes aprendieron en sus clases de
álgebra o de pre cálculo que para
desplazar una función porsche hacia la
derecha sólo tenemos que reemplazar
nuestra fe con una p - por lo que
nuestra función amarilla quedaría efe
dt - y para asegurarnos de que esto está
bien lo que voy a hacer es imaginarme
qué pasaría si t fuera igual a c
cuando te es igual hace que menos se va
a ser igual a cero así que voy a tener
efe de cero cuando te es igual hace el
valor de la función va a ser equivalente
a nuestra función ft que está en color
verde lo que tiene sentido así que si
tenemos uno más arriba de sé si esto es
más uno entonces vamos a tener
efe de c + 1 - c + gm se nos va a quedar
efe de 1 por lo que va a ser el mismo
valor de f de uno solo que desplazado lo
cual tiene sentido ya que si tenemos
este número f 1 aquí pues va a ser
equivalente al que está de este otro
lado sólo que desplazado un espacio de c
y bueno como yo desplace esta función
pues en teoría ustedes podrían tener
toda esta parte que continúa abajo de c
sin embargo yo lo estoy definiendo que
esta función va a mostrarse a partir del
valor de c lo que está antes vale 0 así
que como voy a poner en ceros todo lo
que está antes de ser
creo que es obvio ya que comencé este
vídeo hablándoles de la función escalón
unitario así que qué pasaría si yo
multiplico mis funciones que el unitario
por esto que va a pasar bueno voy a
tener una nueva función que va a ser mi
función escalón c dt
x efe dt menos
y qué es lo que va a suceder
hasta que llegamos al valor de c
todo va a ser cero antes de mi valor se
en el momento en el que llegó mi valor
se va a tener el valor de mi función t
menos en el momento que yo alcanzó el
valor se me funciona escalón se
convierte en 1
esto se vuelve uno y nos queda entonces
la función de tm no sé cómo te va a ser
de mayor pues va a restar se está menos
por lo que nos va a quedar el valor de
la función evaluada de 0 en adelante
esta es una función construida bastante
útil y en un momento vamos a ver la
transformada de la plaza de esto y así
ustedes podrán apreciar porque esto es
una función muy útil pero al menos
ustedes ya saben de qué se trata y cómo
es que desplazan a una función y ponen
ceros todo lo que se encuentra antes de
este punto de desplazamiento y ya que
les acabo de decir que esta es una
función muy útil deberíamos agregar la
transformada de laplace de esta función
en nuestra tabla de transformadas de la
plaza así que vamos a hacerlo vamos a
hacer la transformada de la plaza
y esto de nuestra función escalón se de
te vamos a hacerlo de momento en forma
general y en los siguientes vídeos
veremos cómo aplicar esto pero al menos
debemos comprobar por nosotros mismos
cuál es la transformada de la plaza de
esto bueno la transformada de laplace de
cualquier cosa recordemos que es es la
integral de 0 a infinito de a la menos 7
x la función lo que pusimos a
transformar en este caso nuestra función
escalón de cdt multiplicada por la
función
efe dt menos c de menos c
dt y esto pues en general se ve bastante
difícil de evaluar
pero quizás podríamos encontrar alguna
forma de sustituir algo para poder
apreciar esto así que vamos a hacer una
sustitución aquí
déjenme elegir una variable adecuada
bueno podremos usar x ya que no estamos
ocupando x en ningún lugar aquí x
en algunas clases presentan estos
alfabetos en latín que por sí solos ya
son difíciles de comprender y hacen que
el aprendizaje sea un poco más complejo
por lo que vamos a usar aquí una equis
normal común y corriente y aquí nuestra
x va a ser igual a t menos vamos a
usarla para sustituir
si tenemos latte en ambos lados podremos
decir que t es igual a x 6 vamos a ver
qué podemos hacer con esta sustitución
ahora si obtenemos la derivada en ambos
lados de esta igualdad vamos a tener de
x va a ser igual a bueno de hecho es de
x con respecto a de t
esto va a ser igual a 1 porque se es una
constante si multiplicamos ambos lados
por de t nos va a quedar que de x es
igual a de t y esa es una buena
sustitución bueno como vamos a tener
entonces nuestra integral con esta
sustitución esta integral va a hacer
cuando te es igual a 0 y cuando te tiene
infinito que pasa cuando te es igual a
cero qué pasa con esta x cuando ésta t
es igual a cero
nuestra x va a ser igual a menos bueno
de hecho antes de ver esta parte
permíteme regresarme un paso anterior a
este aunque podríamos continuar haciendo
lo que estamos haciendo pero creo que
sería un poquito más complicado la
explicación podemos simplificar lo
bastante antes de entrar a este punto
vamos a regresar a nuestra integral
antes si quisiéramos nuestra sustitución
vamos a tomar la integral de cero
y vamos a hermano como luce esta
integral como se ve esa función cuando
es 0 tenemos esta función escalón aquí
por lo que toda esta expresión va a ser
igual a 0 toda esta expresión va a ser
cero antes de llegar al valor de c
debido a que estamos hablando de una
función escalón unitario todo esto por
definición va a ser igual a cero hasta
que llegamos al valor c así que podemos
decir que esencialmente no tenemos que
tomar la integrada de cuando te es igual
a cero hasta cuando te tiene infinito
sino cuando te es igual a c así que
vamos a reescribir esta integral podemos
reescribir nuestra integral desde que te
es igual a c hasta que te tiende a
infinito de al menos 7 x 1 c que es
nuestra función escalón unitario que
llegue al valor de c por la función de t
menos
dt y aquí les quiero indicar que esta
función a escalón unitario que tenemos
aquí ya no nos es útil ya fue
incorporada dentro de estos elementos de
la integral
por lo que la podemos quitar de aquí y
quiero que esto quede muy claro lo que
hice yo aquí fue modificar nuestro
límite inferior de la integral de 0 a c
y bueno ustedes se dieron cuenta porque
lo hice al analizar el comportamiento de
la función escala unitario en este caso
si mantenemos esta función aquí va a ser
igual a 0 hasta que lleguemos al valor
de c y por definición la integral es el
área bajo una curva aquí antes del valor
de s no tendríamos curva alguna así que
todo esto va a ser igual a 0 para todos
los valores menores a c y una vez que
lleguemos al valor de c esta integral va
a ser igual a ala menos st por efe
dt menos hasta este momento es cuando
vamos a poder tener ya nuestra función
así que si queremos encontrar el área
bajo la curva todo esto va a ocurrir a
partir del valor de c en adelante así
que en lugar de integrar desde igual a 0
a 7 igual infinito comenzamos a integrar
es igual a c hasta que éste tiende a
infinito y a partir del valor de nuestra
función escalón unitario va a ser igual
a 1 en todos los rangos de valores de t
a partir de c así que bien podemos
ignorarlo podemos simplificar nuestra
integral definida la integrada de t
igual hace hasta t que tiende a infinito
de al menos 7 x
efe dt - dt
y esto nos simplifica bastante las
operaciones por eso es que quise hacer
la sustitución primero para simplificar
por el cambio de variable y los límites
de las integrales lo hubiéramos podido
hacer pero iba a ser un poquito más
complicado pero bueno ahora regresemos a
la parte en la que usamos la sustitución
de x igual a t menos no está integral se
va a convertir cuando t es igual a sé
qué pasa con x a pues x es igual a 0 y
cuando te tiene infinito bueno pues va a
ser un número muy grande - se va a
seguir siendo un número muy grande por
lo que aquí sigue siendo infinito
y esta va a ser la integral de al menos
s pero en lugar de t vamos a sustituir
el valor de x y xi dijimos que x es
igual a tm no sé entonces x + c
y ahora lo vamos a multiplicar por la
función de tm no sé pero vamos a usar la
sustitución x + m no se quede en x
y ahora dt es igual de equis así que
sustituimos aquí de x
y ahora esto comienza a verse
interesante esto es igual pues va a ser
igual a nuestra integral de 0 a infinito
y permíteme expandir un poco esto de ala
menos s x menos s porsche por fx de x
bueno y ahora esto a que es igual vamos
a factorizar esto está ese dice que no
tiene que ver con nuestra integral ya
que no tiene ningún término en x
así que vamos a reescribir todo esto de
manera que nos queda la integral
impropia de 0 infinito
lo escribo aquí para que no se confunden
este término de no vamos a escribir en
colores diferentes
al menos ese por x x el ala menos sc
tienen una base en común si yo me
explicar a estos dos pues simplemente
sumaría los exponentes así que es lo
mismo x f x de x
y si vemos este término de la ccc es un
valor constante no tiene ningún término
en x por lo que lo podemos sacar de
nuestra integral y nos quedaría entonces
el ala menos ss x la integral de 0 a
infinito de ala menos sx-f x de x
bueno recordemos que es lo que estamos
haciendo aquí
lo que estamos haciendo es encontrar la
transformada de la plaza de nuestra
función escalón unitario y dese el valor
de c
qué es una función de t x una función
desplazada
dt menos
y ahora vemos que esto es igual a lo que
acabamos de encontrar recordamos que
hicimos una sustitución y simplificamos
y nos queda
a la - sc por la integral de 0 a
infinito
al menos s x por fx
x hoy lo escribo mejor de x
esto que es suena interesante no a qué
les parece conocido esto pues esta es la
transformada de laplace de x recordemos
que la transformada de la plaza de una
función de o de una función en x puede
ser cualquiera transformada de la plaza
de ft es igual a la integral impropia de
0 a infinito
a la menos st por ft
dt si aquí sustituimos la t por x nos
queda esta otra función
puedo poner x puedo poner yale no
importa éstas son letras oops aquí debe
ser una que en lugar de una x de la
misma manera pude haber escrito
la transformada de la plaza de efe
igual a la integral impropia de 0 a
infinito de a la menos s porque por efe
y de aquí pueden haber puesto cualquier
otra letra cuando hacemos la integral
ustedes han visto que estas variables
desaparecen y nos queda todo en términos
de s esto va a ser igual a una función f
mayúscula de s así que esto es
interesante porque tenemos la
transformada de la plaza de ft
multiplicado por un factor escalar así
que ahora podemos mostrar que la
transformada de la plaza la transformada
de la plaza de nuestra función escalón
unitario dt multiplicado por la función
de menos se va a ser igual
al menos es ese
y es la misma de acá x la transformada
de la plaza no sé qué está pasando con
esto es transformada de la plaza de ft
y esto va a ser igual a la menos sc por
la transformada de la plaza de ft aquí
ya está mejor escrito
este es nuestro resultado excelente ya
tenemos este resultado pero que
significa que podemos hacer con esto
bueno imaginemos que queremos encontrar
la transformada de la plaza de nuestra
función escalón que comienza en pie dt y
digamos que
lo multiplicamos por el seno el seno de
t - y lo estamos desplazando esta
cantidad no sé qué está pasando con esta
pluma creo que voy a tener que pasar
esto para ver qué está pasando ok
mil disculpas porque tuve que hacer una
pausa aquí ya que estaba teniendo
problemas con mi tableta digital de
dibujo pero ahora vamos a reescribir los
resultados que acabamos de obtener la
transformada de la plaza de nuestra
función a escalón unitario que comiencen
sé dt multiplicada por una función que
está siendo desplazada por un valor ce a
la derecha va a ser igual
a la menos c por s por la transformada
de la plaza de f dt la función efe dt
sin el desplazamiento este fue nuestro
gran descubrimiento en este vídeo y esto
puede parecer un resultado muy extraño
sin embargo lo podemos aplicar como
podemos hacerlo y aquí es donde estaba
yo cuando mi tableta la pluma de mi
tableta comenzó a portarse mal
forma de la plaza de nuestra función
escalón unitario a partir de pi x
el seno de t desplazado a la derecha y
esto sería igual a
a las menos
en este caso es pink así que es menos pi
por s por la transformada de la plaza de
nuestra función sin el desplazamiento de
seno dt
y por supuesto nosotros ya sabemos cuál
es la transformada de la plaza de seno
de t es uno entre s cuadrada más uno así
que la transformada de la plaza de toda
esta cosa que se ve bastante complicada
ahora sabemos qué es esto multiplicado
por esto o lo escribimos
a la menos people s / s cuadrada + 1 en
los siguientes vídeos haremos un par de
ejemplos más al respecto y estaremos
yendo y viniendo entre los dominios de
ese y de t
al igual que seguiremos trabajando con
la transformada de la plaza y les voy a
mostrar por qué esto es útil para tomar
e invertir varias transformadas de la
plaza